here we are on cut day and it looks like
desean watson's going to be a texan and
as all of those moving parts are moving
around and everything going on in new
england it is now time to bring the man
of the hour certainly from the week and
the senior nfl reporter of yahoo sports
charles robertson here on the rich
housing show how are you doing charles
doing well mazel tov thank you sir very
thank you very popular in miami these
days
well so
um
what's going on let's start with the
present here and you can you know
whatever you want to uh sprinkle in from
what you heard over the weekend and
leading up to that
into what is going on with the sean
watson the dolphins and texans as we're
currently conversing on this tuesday
yeah well i look i can tell you right
now the the
houston texans are are going to have to
relent on pick protections when it comes
to desean watson and
you know the i i understand dolphins
fans um want to look at the situation
and say well you look we're going into
the season with tua which is significant
and
the houston texas are going to go into
the season you know at least at this
point this is the plan to go into the
season with deshawn watson on the 53-man
roster but the reality is
why we're sitting here talking about
that is simply because the houston
texans are refusing to
look at an exchange of of draft picks
for deshaun watson and give protections
away and
it's something that caused i think the
carolina panthers over a period of time
to say there's there's too much risk
there and if we cannot mitigate the risk
we have to clap our hands and walk away
from the table um i think it kept uh the
philadelphia eagles at an arm's length
for a while and and really kept them
from engaging more deeply into a desean
watson pursuit than they ever did
and also for the denver broncos who i
you know i think genuinely were and
you know would probably still be
interested in desean watson if the
houston texans were willing to say look
we don't have to have everything we
don't have to have our price and then on
top of it also have pick protections as
well now you know the dolphins and i'm
just look i'll just say brian flores
brian force really respects the football
talent and i'm going to say again the
football talent of course of desean
watson okay we can you have to separate
um you know for a moment when you're
talking about potential deal you have to
separate
how he's viewed from a football
perspective
you know versus how he's viewed in terms
of the the civil litigation and the
criminal investigations that are
underway from a football perspective
brian flores looks at deshaun watson as
a top five quarterback a
um a player who will push to be you know
a first or second team all-pro player
every single year at the position for
the next 10 years
everything that he's cracked up to be
that everyone celebrated prior to march
prior to everything coming out
from the civil and criminal end of of
you know his life right now
um but that said
there is the other half of the equation
and that is
um the reticence that teams experience
even if they like him if they're still
at the table willing to entertain
training for him
it's being protected for what happens
after that trade occurs and if the
texans are going to sit here which is
what is occurring right now the texans
are going to sit here and continue to
say we're not we're not giving up pick
protections and we're we're going to
continue to push for this full price
which
once again three first round picks two
second round picks that is what they
consider a full price offer
um it's going to be hard to to
consummate a deal
but
the idea that just because the season's
starting that this is wraps it's a wrap
and and miami's out for good
again
brian flores had the opportunity and i
can't underscore this enough
very smart guy my report came out on
friday had a whole day to think about it
knowing the questions were coming had
the opportunity to go we have our
starting quarterback not going to take
these questions anymore we're done
um we're moving forward we're not
trading for any starting quarterback so
let's just get off this and
and that's it we're finished
didn't happen and i know you know people
are going to say that's not proof of
anything but
i've covered the league 20 years rich
you've been around it forever i mean
we've
we've seen this happen before and there
is an economy of language that that
matters and coaches and flores is a very
bright guy
could end this any moment he wants to
well
let's that you just laid a lot out there
charles so let me let me just get right
into it then um
totally makes sense that the texans want
watson gone
totally makes sense that watson still
wants out totally makes sense
that watson wants to control where he
wants to go
totally makes sense that the texans are
like yeah we're not going to give you
any protection this is desean watson and
totally makes sense
that the dolphins would want protection
because of what's going on and what they
don't know
and let's be honest there's
i'll say it a lot in south florida where
individuals could be
called massage therapists i mean so
there's there's a lot of
risk in moving parts in everything right
here but on what planet does everybody
think this sort of thing
is going to be pulled off where
everybody gets what they want
a week and a half before the season why
even attempt it
why even attempt it from let's remove
the text inside because they want them
off
why were the dolphins even attempted why
would they even
attempt it
charles
i
i can't sit here and defend the the
thought process of um
why
look i i've written in the past i've
written multiple times since march that
essentially we're in a radioactive
situation with a player where from a
risk standpoint from a
public relations standpoint from if you
even want to go there and you know look
again innocent until proven proven
guilty he's being looked at by everyone
right now okay so it's not like it's
just one body and you know um this is a
situation where someone could do a
sloppy investigation
and nothing happens um this is
the fbi this is the harris county
prosecutor's office houston police
departments the nfl which will
eventually conclude their investigation
after uh the criminal side wraps up um
you know it's there's a there's a
morality risk here too depending on how
you feel about the allegations and you
know what your level of belief is and
and you know what bears out
once all these investigations are
completed i can't answer to why
you would want to
even entertain that element of risk now
that said
um
i can't speak to the personal
relationship maybe in the past or you
know the connections between
you know brian flores and people around
um desean watson what he knows about the
kid personally um i when i went through
my training camp tour
went through philadelphia went through
carolina went through denver you know
a multitude of other teams they all know
i live in houston they all ask about
sean watson like what's going on there
and the first question i'd ask them is
did any you have an inkling of this like
when she's coming out of clemson you
know work like anything nothing nothing
nothing i've heard
it's why it's so surprising you know um
charles it's so surprising to everybody
that this has happened but i guess the
reason why i'm saying even attempt it
knowing that you know i guess you might
get nick casario
on on a day where
maybe you didn't get any rest the night
before and yeah i'll i'll give you
desean watson and he'll wind up a three
you know after a six-game suspension you
know and then you get him for the next
eight years you know or yeah
it just makes
no sense on every level and the reason
why i'm asking it under this case is
charles robinson yahoo sports here
do they not like tua and i i no it's
nothing to do with tour that has nothing
to do with it it's desean watson but
it's not desean watson it's desean
watson and all of that baggage and all
of the question marks that come around
all things being equal
there's no conversation of course you go
get to sean what but all things being
equal deshaun watson wasn't going to be
available you know uh under these
circums under the circumstances of
january through march once march hit and
everything that came out so what do you
hear about too because i didn't even
hear that tua would be going back to
houston in a trade no you would right
yeah i don't i don't from my
from my discussions with my sources in
houston two would not be included in par
in part of that deal that you know they
weren't interested in two of them
weren't interested in jalen hurts you
know when you know those confident sam
darnold all these different things so
um wow
you know i can't i can't speak to
you know
what specifically
you know the evaluation is internally in
miami on two although
i can say that there's no question in
the minds of the decision makers in
miami he's taken the steps that they
expect you know they drafted him
um to to improve you know to
every you know how it is you draft a kid
like that it's not going to be perfect
and everybody's not going to be you know
justin herbert walk in and light the
league on fire even peyton manning
through 28 interceptions rookie season
right um you're going to want to see the
positive steps so he continue to make
the same mistakes over and over does he
have the right mentality in the meeting
room is he the leader we thought he was
is he tough is he gritty you you talk to
mac jones and all i heard leaning in
that draft was
you know that extra bit of um you know
chippiness and leadership and matt jones
talking trash with nick saban when he's
running the scout team and things like
that so you know there's this whole
other side of um the mental element of a
quarterback and and how he fits inside
your culture that you have to evaluate
as well well the dolphins have to make
that decision about tua now that said
it looks like he has done up until this
point everything they would ask but i
will say this too
um
you know this is something i've said
before but i'll reiterate it you know
when the season started last year
most rams fans wouldn't believe that
jared goff wouldn't be a ram you know
come the middle of the offseason you
know i think 49ers fans had questions
about jimmy garoppolo but you know i
don't think there was any clarity that
hey you know they're going to draft a
kid with the third pick and jimmy's days
are going to be numbered um you know
carson wentz there was no thought
process the beginning of last season
that carson montz wasn't going to you
know work back into what they thought he
could be that mvp level player years ago
all these things
things change and evaluations change and
i think
um if anything if sean mcvay has shown
us anything if kyle shanahan's showing
us anything david tepper pulling the
plug on teddy so quickly teddy
bridgewater has shown us anything
there's a mentality in the nfl right now
amongst some aggressive decision makers
that do i feel like this is a
quarterback i can win a super bowl with
and and if
it's either a question mark or a no
what are we doing here
and
i think from a talent standpoint again
if brian flores is looking at justin
watson saying
it's a yes it's definitely a yes
um
am i going to have an opportunity
you know to go out and get a kid like
this again and oh by the way he you know
he has an extension that as these other
quarterback deals roll in
it's looking better every single year
and it's going to look a lot better when
justin herbert signs his extension and
the air of you know
quarterback salaries are rolling into so
there are you know there are other
things to measure and it doesn't
necessarily mean two is a bad player
but
have we forgotten what our opinion was
of deshaun watson in january you know in
february so just so just i'm sorry
so just to re reiterate repeat texans in
your estimation have not in any of these
trades that with carolina knocking on
the door and the eagles knocking on the
door
and anybody else uninterested in taking
the other team's quarterback back in the
trade not at all just want draft picks
not as i've been told no that it's a no
that they want to move forward you know
they draft a quarterback in the third
round
um davis mills
that's what it is or they used to use
all these for the the capital that
they're getting from other teams to go
uh you know make sure they get spencer
rattler or whatever the hell they want
like that's that's their potential
mindset in houston
i think well i think part of it's the
evaluation of other quarterbacks too you
know how did they feel about these other
quarterbacks i mean it's you know that
plays into it as well and you know it's
they're also in the midst of
as you said whatever the compensation be
let's say it's three first round picks
and two second round picks that's
compensation to reposition yourself in
the draft if you see the quarterback you
like
as we saw this last offseason
quarterbacks now migrate in the nfl
quarterbacks that we wouldn't expect and
you know
some maybe nick casario is sitting here
and again this this particular point i'm
about to make is speculation maybe maybe
nick's nick cacera says
i can build out a strong roster and who
knows aaron rodgers you know it looks
like you're in rogers may may be someone
that could enter the trade market you
know come off season depending on what
happens in green bay with a set up there
um
you know the the saints have a starting
quarterback in jameis winston that
you know
it you can resolve your quarterback
situation without necessarily having to
you know include a guy in the deal now
and i know it naturally would make sense
to me and i i thought all along it would
make sense particularly once miami
surfaced
in january february oh well two would be
a part of a package to come back but
that has not been
what i've been told when i've had
conversations with people inside houston
that no it would be picks we want a
package of picks and if and if it's not
with picks and players i think they
would be looking for like starting
caliber defensive players on top of
pitch so last one for you on this
charles robinson so if the texans are
sitting here saying no no protection on
picks and every team's saying we want
protection on picks
um is there is there any clarity maybe
behind the scenes
where the dolphins
knowing this sort of stuff could get out
and they don't mind having a tire kick
on desean watson no with tua getting set
to start the season and everybody else
with carolina and sam darnold and
philadelphia
having with jalen hurts that they they
don't mind potentially you know
obviously they do deep down but
knowing that it's worth taking the risk
is there any clarity on desean watson's
criminal civil
liability investigation situation at all
that we might not know that you're
hearing about charles well it in terms
of
the one bit of clarity i can say is that
i do think and and
desean watson's attorney rusty hardness
said this publicly a few times that the
nfl's investigation is
sort of in limbo because there's an
element of when the nfl you know when
lisa friel nfl they do these
investigations
there's always sort of what i refer to
as a grand finale interview and the way
that that usually happens is they
collect every bit of evidence or you
know interviews whatever
information they think is germane to
their investigation and then at the end
they come in and they do the the final
sort of pivotal interview with the
player and that has not happened with
deshaun watson and from what rusty hart
has indicated
at least twice publicly
the reason why the nfl has not done that
and what they have indicated to him is
that you know they don't want to step on
the fact that there's you know uh
parallel criminal investigations that
are going on they don't want to step
into someone else's world and somehow
taint you know by by sharing information
or asking certain questions um the
the investigation that's going on
criminally so they they're in limbo
they're they're essentially waiting for
those to wrap up the grand jury
investigation the subpoenas have gone
out
you know um it's in a process of
gathering information
we don't know whether or not because of
a 90 every grand jury rotates in texas
every 90 days so we don't we're not told
sort of where the current grand jury is
in terms of that 90 days if they're on
the 85th day right chances are
information is not going to be presented
to this grand jury on the 85th day
they'll wait until the next rotation
starts
so he may not even really in terms of
the investigation what a grand jury
hears about this it might not even start
for a period of two days two weeks a
month and a half i mean that's there's
no clarity and they don't tell that's
it's all
sealed that's none of this is public and
i to me the fbi both lawyers involved we
don't know what that guys they've asked
questions they're not telling us
anything they're not tipping us off to
anything other than the questions they
ask we have no clue
the depth of it you know how how long it
will take or if there's ever anything
that's going to happen i i think russia
probably put it best when at one point
he said like
it could just and we don't even know
they never tell us they're not going to
tip us off to it so
um i think the houston police department
is really that
the the alleged victims who have spoken
to houston police department that's all
going to be tied into the harris county
prosecutor's office so from a criminal
aspect of it
it could be months and months you know
and and again
the fact that the nfl did not choose to
put him on the exempt list right is a
fairly clear indication nfl says what we
have now in front of us it does not rise
to the level of us making that decision
and that's where we stand so then he's
going to be on the 53-man and what like
a uh uh
the third quarterback inactive not
dressed just tell him to go home pay him
until that's how desean watson's 2021
season is going to be
played out yeah i mean that's what we
get what we've seen in preseas which is
he's going to be a member of
of the team he's on the roster but he's
separate from the roster he's not going
to be someone who's going to be reactive
on game days
and wow um you know they'll carry them
now now here's here's something that's
important
you could drum up say an injury like
okay he's had you know trainers work on
him we sat out practice a few times what
he has said is a lower body injury the
texans to be frank here don't fully
believe that's true they feel like he
sort of said some of these things to
keep himself off the field away from the
cameras
um but if you leaned into that you could
say you know we're putting my injured
reserve he's got a calf boy he's got
whatever soft tissue injury
so he goes on injured reserve three
weeks and you know into being on injured
reserve then basically you can resume
the potential of trading him keeping him
on the 53-man roster past four o'clock
today means you continue to have the
avenue to trade him at any moment any
minute between now and you know
the trade deadline so
keeping him on the 53-man roster is a
there's a tactical element that makes
sense here if there is a chance he could
be traded
three days from now you know two weeks
from now but doing the injured reserve
route that's going to put him you know
in limbo for at least a three week
period where you're not going to be able
to deal them all right and then the la i
keep having questions this would be my
last one because i was going to ask you
about other stuff in the nfl so what was
the dolphin's plan get him get get get
him in
have have you know protection in terms
of the draft choices and then start him
like week one show up in new england
with all these questions and stick him
out there in front of the media and the
possibility of
of everything that that's going on with
him dropping in their lap in the middle
of the season it's jacoby brissette time
like literally and then they'll just
weather all those storms and and then
eventually you know in 2022 2023 no one
will
remember how crazy 2021 was and they've
got desean watson at a
at a highly affordable rate that's
literally what their plan was
i it well the answer i mean there's
actually the question at least in the
immediacy i think the questions even go
deeper than that because remember this
is a guy who's
not practiced at least you know not in
the in the typical sense of how a
quarterback practices in the preseason
so it's not like he's been out there
throwing balls he hasn't played in
preseason games and taking part in joint
practices so there's the fitness level
like is he ready
would he even be ready to step out and
start throwing a ball immediately
if if he wasn't and two is still on your
rosters that means tua starts the season
as a starter and then all of a sudden
you switch to deshaun watson when he's
ready wow doesn't seem you know that
like that to me
trust me the timing of this like i get
it people it's not like i ignore the
question like people have great
questions
i don't have those questions too right
um i know and then but
again
we don't know i don't know personally
what work behind the scenes the texans
or excuse me the the dolphins have done
in terms of speaking to the league
office speaking to roger goodell doing
their own work on what you know the
allegations are
how this could run its course criminally
and then also the league investigation
and
you know
every general manager i spoke to who's
involved in this has spoken to rusty
hart and i can tell you this rusty
harden that's sean watson's attorney has
maintained from day one with like
unequivocally
the guy is innocent i'm going to show
you he's innocent we're going to go to
court and show he's innocent they want
to settle and we are demanding that if
we do settle there's no nba so we can
talk about how all this went the money
everything we want everything
transparent
and then you have to ask yourself okay
so if he's saying that and the dolphins
are doing their own brand of work
how do we know what the dolphins have
found i mean what do what if brian
flores says i know the kid you know i
know the kid in a kid's background we've
done work on them all these different
things maybe i believe
that
he hasn't had his day to to
talk about what's happened the
allegations and let this whole thing
unfold maybe maybe there's a feeling
internally there that people could feel
differently about this six months from
now than they do today
you know once things start to sort of
unfold
either in front of a grant here this
could change dramatically people really
need to understand this if this goes
before a grand jury okay
if a grand jury sits here and says we're
not indicting you know we're going to do
what's called a no bill which is there's
no there's a need we don't have any
charges for him to plead to
um to be indicted would mean he
instantly would have to plead to
whatever charges the grand jury comes up
with if the grand jury comes back and
says we have a no bill determination
that means we have nothing for you to to
plead to there are no charges here that
we we are advancing for you to plead to
at that point that changes significantly
because now you have a grand jury that
has sat weighed the evidence heard if
they chose to heard interviews right
from the alleged you know victims in
this situation and said we got nothing
for you
that's that is a significant titanic
moment in in the legal process and i
think it would
very much change the narrative for nfl
teams when it comes to the the reticence
to take a look at him in terms of a
trade charles thanks for the call i got
a jet i had too many questions probably
more than my uh radio clock would allow
thanks for the call we'll chat soon
absolutely be safe hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here